hello everyone my name is xiaowei and
i'm a software engineer in microsoft
cognitive services team in cloud and ai
my manager is legion and our team works
on computer vision research in the areas
of vision language pre-tuning image
captioning and
object detection today i'm going to talk
about
our recent work on image captioning
including the technologies we used to
substantially improve the performance
for the image captioning service
and first i will give an overview what
is the goal of image captioning and
what we need to learn for this task
in general image captioning aims to
generate a natural language sentence to
describe the content
in the image for example giving this
image as input
the capture output is a baseball player
catching a ball
this capability is required in many
applications
that need to translate images into words
but it is also very challenging
so let's consider an exercise
so how would you describe an image to
another person
who cannot see it imagine that the other
person cannot see any objects in the
image
so you will need to visually identify
every detail and decide what to describe
take this image as an example you see a
lot of scenes in the image
one person on the left is sending and
talking
and there is also a poster stand next to
her and she is looking at the poster
other people are sitting on chairs and
listening and they are all
in a room and in the background there
are windows and buildings outside the
window
now we see that an image could contain
lots of information
and when you want to describe it clearly
first
you will need to know exactly what
everything is
where it is what is doing in relation to
other objects
and note other attributes like color or
position of the objects
and if it's in the foreground or
background
moreover giving all this information you
have to decide what is more
important to describe and what is not
to generate a caption like a person
giving a presentation to a group of
people
you need to combine all these above
skills and this exercise shows that
the image captioning is a complex task
and requires a wide range of knowledge
and to translate the skills into
artificial intelligence
we need to train the model to learn the
relationships between words and visual
objects the model should be able to
recognize everything
which is the ultimate goal of computer
vision
and the model should also generate a
fluent sentence
which is studied in natural language
processing
so the image captioning problem actually
lies in the intersection of these two
fields
and it has attracted great attention
from both vision and language
communities
in today's talk we will talk about
how to improve the performance of image
captioning with recent
vision language preaching approach we
will cover our latest work
object semantics align pre-training
which is short as
oscar this method uses
large-scale image text pairs to
significantly improve the performance of
general image captioning
we will also cover another work of a
visual vocabulary pre-training
which is short as vivo this method is
developed
for novel object captioning in the
absence of
capture annotations and we will discuss
the key principles to improve the
performance
and how we address the core challenges
in caption generation
to build an image captioning model of
previous
works proposed to use the pre-trained
convolutional neural networks to
extract image features and then use
recurrent neural networks to process the
image features and generate a sequence
of words one by one
in the auto regressive manner here the
image feature
can be a great feature map which is
usually the
last layer feature output of a resident
model
and in recent years people also use the
detection model
such as the faster rcn model to detect
the body boxes in the image
and extract the features from the
detected boxes
this is called image region feature this
kind of
image region feature has gained a wide
popularity after it shows
a superior performance on several public
benchmarks
another important trend is pre-training
that is to pretend the model on massive
amounts of data before fine tuning on
downstream tasks
it has been showing a different field
that
pre-training helps to learn better
representations
and less benefits the downstream tasks
for example imagenet pre-training is
widely used for computer vision tasks
such as
object detection and segmentation
the pre-trained model birth is better
used in
language tasks and lastly the
pre-training
on image text pairs has been popular for
vision language tasks
such as the visual question answering
and image captioning
and in the language community a
pre-training world
embeddings has been studied for quite a
long time
including elmo gpt and the birds
especially with the success of birds the
first
preaching then fine-tuned scheme has
gained more popularity from wider
audience
one of the differences between birth and
the previous
preaching models is the use of
bi-directional attention in the
transformer layers
that is for each token it can attend to
all the tokens in the input sequence
in this way the representation of the
token depends on all the tokens before
and after it and the bird model has two
model sizes
the bird-based model consists of 12
transformer encoder layers and results
in 110 million parameters
and birth large model consists of 24
layers
weighs 340 meeting parameters
and to preaching the birth model on
large-scale text corporate
the input is a sequence of words and the
input
may consist of one sentence or a pair of
sentences
and in the input we use the special
token
cls here to indicate the start of the
sentence
and the special token scp which
shown here to indicate the end of the
sentence
and during training some of the tokens
in the sentences
are randomly masked and after feeding
the input to the model
we get a sequence of hidden
representations
corresponding to the input tokens
and there are two pre-training tasks
the first is to predict the mask tokens
in the sentence
this is done by getting the hidden
representations corresponding to the
mask tokens
and transforming them with a linear
layer to predict
the token id in vocabulary the second
is a conducted a pair of sentences
such as a and a b this is to predict
whether sentence b is the next sentence
of
sentence a and here the first token
cls is used for the binary
classification in the next
sentence prediction
the birth model has been fine-tuned on a
variety of
natural language processing tasks and
achieved state-of-the-art results
and this validates the improvement of
the word representations learned by
birth
now we look at how to adapt the approach
of birth in english and language
preaching
the goal of vision language preaching is
to learn
cross-model representations of both
image and
text input and which will be adapted to
serve
various downstream vision language tasks
by fantuni
vision language pre-training is
typically conducted on text image pairs
for the text part the input is processed
in the same way as invert to get a
sequence of
word embeddings
and for the image part we use
pre-chained object detection model to
detect
objects in the image and extract the
region features
then we use a linear layer to transform
the
extracted region features into the same
dimension as the word embeddings
and after we get the features of input
from the
two modalities of visual features and
the
word embeddings to learn the cross model
representation
we concatenate the word and image
features
into a sequence and then use the
multi-layer transformer model to conduct
the pre-training
the model takes a visual features and
it's paired
text as input and relies on the
self-attention mechanism to learn image
text alignment
and produce the cross-model
contextualize the representations
during preaching it's straightforward to
use
similar objectives as births and the
bi-directional attention
but for different downstream tasks we
may need some extra changes
for example for the understanding tasks
like a visual question answering
is fine to use the bad directional
attention
that is each token can attend to all the
tokens in the input
however for the generation tasks like
image captioning to simulate the
generation process
we have to use sequence to sequence
attention mask
that is we only allow tokens to attend
to
positions before it but not after it
and this is implemented by modifying the
attention mask
the image part can only see the image
and the word tokens in the text part
can see the image and the words before
it including itself
but the word cannot see the words after
it
during inference the model will take the
image features as
input and generate the words from left
to right
in the autoregressive manner and
therefore
by altering the attention mask
understanding tasks and
generation tasks are unified in a single
framework
and as the vision language pre-training
is
crucial to the performance on downstream
vision language tasks
there has been a lot of work on
improving the pre-training method
here we propose oscar
this method has created the state of art
on cocoa caption
and oscar proposes to use object
text detected in in the image as input
also unlike other visual language
pretriny methods that use
image text pair as input the input of
oscar contains
three parts first is the caption
sentence
and second is the detected object text
and the third is the image features
uh here the object types are the
language representation of the detected
visual concepts
and in the paper it is shown that object
text can be used as
anchor points to ease the learning of
semantic alignments
between images and attacks and this is
the key reason why oscar outperforms
previous pre-training methods
and these figures illustrate the process
that the oscar model represents an image
text
pair into semantic space here figure a
shows an example of image and the paired
text
in the image the object detection model
can detect
a dog and a couch and the word dog
and coach also appear in the text a dog
is sitting on a couch
in the figure c we show the semantic
spaces of
both visual features and word embeddings
in the upper figure the yellow triangle
is the visual feature of the couch in
the image
and the right square is the visual
feature of the dock in the image
in this example image the two visual
features are very close to each other
because of the overlapped regions
and this renders ambiguities for the
extracted
visual features however as shown in the
lower side in figure c
dog and coach are distinctive in the
word embedding space
again here the yellow triangle is the
embedding of the
word cult in the sentence and the red
square is the embedding of the word
dog in the sentence so here we can see
that
the word semantic semantic space is more
representative
than the image region feature space for
these objects
at the result showing as shown in figure
b
when we try to learn the alignment
between visual and text inputs
the object tags can be used as anchor
points to ease the learning of alignment
and here is the disney visualization of
the cross model representation space
learned by two different models on the
left side
is the baseline model without using
object text
and on the right side is the oscar model
here the plot symbol is the image
features
and the circle symbol is the text
image and text the features of the same
category share the
same color
in the figure we can observe that by
using oscar
the image and text features of the same
object
are closer to each other for example
for the category person in the baseline
model the distance between image and the
text
features is large but in oscar the
distance is much smaller
and now we will describe how to trim the
oscar model
the pre-training of oscar uses 6.5
million
image text pairs the training data is
combined from
several public data sets including
conceptual captions of vqa and
gqa the input of the model
is world tag region triplet
and there are two losses used in
pre-training the first
is the mask token loss to predict the
mass
mask the token in the text or object
text
and the second is the contrastive loss
to predict if the text and the text are
matching with the image
after preaching the model can be
fine-tuned on various
downstream tasks including both the
understanding tasks like
vqa and the generation tasks like image
captioning
and for the captioning task as we talked
in previous slides
the attention mask is modified so that
for each token it can attend to tokens
to the left all the image regions and
object text but it cannot attend to
tokens to the right
to assimilate the generation process
and during inference the captioning
model takes the image features
and detected tabs as input which are the
same as
inferentially and for the text part
at the beginning of generation the input
is the cls token
here which is the special token used to
indicate the start of the sentence
and this cls token is followed by the
mask token
then we run the model to get the
prediction corresponding to the mask
token position now we get the prediction
corresponding to the mask token
and then we will use this predicted
predicted token to replace the mask
token
and after this we attach another mask
token after the predicted token and also
at the end of the sentence to
predict the next token here
you can see here we get the next
predicted token token 2.
and then replace the mask token with the
token tool
and this step is repeated until we
get the eos token which is also a
special token to
use to indicate the end of the sentence
this process will also stop if we reach
the maximum length of the sentence
after fine tuning we can see that the
oscar model achieved the new state of
arts
on six different downstream tasks
including
image text retrieval image captioning on
coco no caps
and visual question answering and an
lvr2
here are some example images of the
image caption models
the baseline model here is uh use the
visual language pre-training but without
object text the yellow colored objects
appear
in both the baseline model and the oscar
model
and blue colored objects appear in only
oscar and
text and the green color objects appear
in the text only
we see that the captions generated by
oscar covers
more object categories and result in
more detailed descriptions of the images
than the baseline
and this is due to the use of accurate
and diverse object tags
because they are the anchor points in
the word embedding space
which can gather the text generation
process
also so far we see how to improve the
performance
of general image captioning by
leveraging a visual language
vision language pre-training on
large-scale image text pairs
and the performance of the captioning
model has been significantly improved
by using the oscar and it can achieve a
really impressive results when it is
trained on large-scale paired image
caption training data
so are we already certified satisfied
with the current captioning framework
the answer is no the reason is that
in real-world images there are a wide
variety of visual objects
and many of them are unseen in the
caption in training data
for models relying on large amounts of
image caption pairs to obtain good
performance
it could be too expensive to collect
enough training data
for all the different categories and
this
resists the challenge of novel object
captioning
that is how to generate captions that
can describe
a novel objects unseen in the paired
image caption training data
let's take this image as an example
here person and coach are common objects
appearing in the widely used
cocoa caption data set also a model
trained on coco can facefully describe
images containing
objects such as person and culture
however the model will fail to generate
a reasonable caption for the image
containing
accordion since the object accordion
is unseen in the caption training
corporal
and to address this problem we propose
a new training scheme we call it vivo
which is short for
visual vocabulary pre-training compared
to
conventional vision language
pre-training methods our pre-training
method shares the same motivation to
learn the
cross-modality semantic alignment
between image and
text however instead of pre-training
on image caption pairs opportunity
scheme uses
image tag pairs so our method does not
rely on caption annotations for
pre-tuning
it can leverage more data sets with only
tag annotations to learn the novel
objects
such as the vision objects which are
originally
developed for the image tagging or
object detection tasks those kinds of
computer vision data sets with image tag
pairs
are readily available at large skill
such as the image net
open images and object 365.
they contain not only more diverse
images
but also much richer visual concepts in
their labels
compared to the caption data sets
available
moreover we can also leverage a large
amount
of unlabeled images and paired with
machine generated text and this makes it
possible to use
unlimited large number of training data
now we talk about what is the proposed
visual vocabulary
here we define visual vocabulary as a
joint embedding space for visual and
attacks modalities
the embedding space is conceptually
illustrated in the upper figure in the
embedding space
image region features and attacks of
semantically similar objects
are mapped into vectors that are close
to each other
for example the visual representations
of
person or men from the image and the
word
imbalance of the tag person and men
are all close to each other and
similarly
the visual representations of the image
region according
and the word embedding of the accordion
and the instrument are also close to
each other
and in preaching we leverage large
amounts of image tag pairs to learn a
rich visual vocabulary
including the novel objects such as
accordion
and these novel objects are color are
colored in yellow here
once the visual vocabulary is pretend
we can fine tune the model using image
caption pairs for caption generation
note that the data set used for fine
tuning could be
very small and only covers limited
visual concepts
so the objects present in a fine-tuning
dataset are only a small subset
of the most commonly occurred objects in
the learned visual vocabulary
and here this uh this limited visual
concepts are colored in blue in the
figure
although these novel objects do not
appear in fine
tuning during inference the model can
still generalize to describe novel
objects
because of the pre-chained visual
vocabulary
here the image at inference time
contains a similar scene of
people sitting in couch and the novel
objects of according
this thing is present in fine tuning and
the novel object
is not present in fine tuning but it is
learned impressiony
visual vocabulary pre-training aims to
learn a joint
embedding a joint representation of
visual and text input
and here we use a multi-layer
transformer model
uh to trim to trim it uh the overview of
our model architecture is shown in the
figure it consists of
multiple transformer encoder layers to
encode the input into a feature vector
and followed by a linear layer with
softmax to predict the word token
now we describe how to train our model
our approach uses a two-stage training
scheme
it consists of vivo pre-tuning and fine
tuning
now we illustrate our approach using the
example showing the image
and first in the pre-training stage
which is showing in figure a
the model learns to label image regions
using text
such as person according and the
training data is
image tag pairs from large-scale vision
datasets such as
open images and the normal object like
accordion is included here in the pre
training then in the fine tuning stage
as shown in figure b the model is
trimmed on small data sets of
image caption pairs such as coco
giving the image caption pair and the
corresponding object text detected
such as the person and a dog the model
learns to generate a sentence
conditioned on the detected visual
objects and text
for example here the caption is a
holding b
uh here a and b are two mask tokens to
predict
here uh the uh the mask token a
could attend to the person in the image
and attack person
and similarly the mask token b
could attend to the dog in the image and
attack
dog and in this way the model learns to
compose a sentence are conditioned on
the image
and the text from the image caption
pairs
it also learns to recognize novel
objects that are
unseen in the image caption pairs but
seen in image tag
pre-training data in this example
as a result as shown in figure c
at inference time the model can
recognize the objects
such as person and accordion and compose
familiar
constituents in a novel way to form a
caption
a person holding a coordinate
in summary the model can generate
captions for novel objects because it
achieves the compositional
generalization
that is it has the ability to make novel
compositions
of familiar constituents which allows
for zero shot generalization to novel
objects for image captioning
here we introduce how we do the how we
implement
the pre-training algorithm during
pre-training
giving a back of text and image regions
will randomly mask
some of the texts and the training
objective is to predict the masked text
however unlike words in captions
tags are not ordered and this and other
nature
may result in ambiguity in tag
prediction
when two tags are masked out
simultaneously
for example if the masked token a person
according we can predict the first
as person second as according or the
other way around
the first predicted as according and
second
predicted as as person
and to resolve this issue we propose to
use hungary match laws to formulate the
tag prediction as a set matching problem
for the predicted tokens p and the
target tokens t
we will find a permutation of target
tokens to minimize the cost function
then the loss is calculated as the
cross-entropy loss between prediction
and target tokens
after permutation and to evaluate our
model's performance
on novel object captioning or we conduct
experiments on no caps
here the no caps benchmark is developed
to evaluate
novel object captioning at skill but the
training data for no caps is the cocoa
data set
and the open images data set cocoa
consists of
image caption pairs and the open images
contains
body boxes and image level tags
the validation and testing images are
selected from
open images validation set it contains
nearly 400 novel objects that are not
already seen in the cocoa dataset
uh it is also worth noting that uh in no
caps
no additional image caption pairs can be
used for training
except coco so the conflict so the
conventional vision language
pre-training methods cannot be used for
no caps
because they rely on large-scale image
caption pairs from datasets like
conceptual captions and each image in
the validation and the test set in no
caps
is labeled with 11 captions 10 of them
are used as
ground choose and the left one is used
to measure the human performance
and this is the human baseline we show
in experiments
we compare our method with up down and
oscar
abdul and oscar are the state of art
results on the no caps benchmark
the training data for baselines is the
cocoa data set
and we use open images for vivo pre
training and
cocoa for fine tuning following prayer
settings
we also report the results after our
model is optimized using
scst which is short for self-critical
sequence training
and generates the captions using
constrained beam search
which is shot for cbs here the
evaluation results on nodecaps
validation and test sets
are showing in the table by leveraging
vivo pretriny
on the open image data set our method
has achieved a significant
improvement compared to other baselines
our plane version
vivo already outperforms up down plus
elmo plus cbs and oscar by a large
margin
and our best results are the new state
of art and surpasses the human cider
score on the overall data side for the
first time
it is worth noting that a constrained
beam surge
brings absolute gains of 17.8
for the up down method and 15.5
for the oscar method but it only
improves
vivo by 3.8 and this suggests that
our model is more capable of generating
captions with
novel objects without explicitly adding
any constraints
and here is the results shown in the
leaderboard
in a following work we achieved even
better results with
vivo by using improved visual features
the visual features are extracted by a
faster rcm model better trend for vision
language tasks
and this again validates the effecting
effectiveness of our proposed vivo
method
here i will select some images
containing novel objects and
visualize the caption results
in the figures the the b
b stands for the baseline model without
vivo pre-training
and v stands for our proposed model with
vivo pre-trini
the novel object is colored in red in
the captions
and it is clear that vivo pre-trained
model is more capable of
recognizing novel objects
moreover we show that our model can
round the recognized objects into image
regions
here we calculate the similarity between
the representations
of a pair of image regions and object
tag
we highlight the pairs with high
similarity scores in the figure for each
object
the bounty box color is brighter when
the similarity score is higher
and these results show that our model
can recognize novel objects
and also localize the novel objects in
image regions
and to get an overview of the
learn the visual vocabulary or in other
words
to get overview of the joint embedding
space
of the visual and text input we
visualize the feature spaces using
disney
in each figure we use an image patch to
represent
the corresponding image feature and use
a marker to represent the word embedded
here we use the same color to indicate
the same object
category the left hand side is the
feature space without fine-tuning for
the captioning task
and the right on the right hand side is
a feature space after fantuni for the
image captioning on cocoa
we see the first baseline model is
random
is randomly initialized and the result
of vivo pre-trini
we see that the visual and text features
are separate
and not aligned at all the second
baseline model is initialized with birth
but
without vivo pre-trini the two
modalities are not aligned at first
but the alignment is improved after
fine-tuning
and especially for the objects
frequently occur in the caption corporal
however for novel objects the alignment
is much worse such as a grip a
strawberry
and a job and this shows the limitation
of
conventional captioning framework on the
problem of
novel object captioning now we look at
our proposed model
the left side is after vivo preaching it
compared to all the bass lines
previously mentioned
vivo pre-training learns a better
cross-model alignment
but only use the image tag pairs
and the right-hand side is after
fine-tuning and with fine-tuning our
image caption pairs
the alignment is further improved
it is clear that the two modalities are
better aligned with our proposed method
and especially for the novel objects
here we can see compared to previous
baselines
for normal objects such as grip
strawberry
and drum and now the distance between
visual and
text features gets much smaller
in summary in this talk first we present
our recent work on visual language
preaching to substantially improve the
performance on general image captioning
and second we propose a vivo
pre-training
that is a cross-modality learning
technique
unlike existing vision language
pre-training methods
vivo pre-training can be conducted
without caption annotations
this opens the possibility of using
vision datasets at a much
larger scale and third
we conduct extensive experiments and
show that
vivo pre-tuning is the key to improve
performance on novel object captioning
and our best model surpasses human
settle score on the benchmark for the
first
time here we provide
more images if you want to learn more
about the performance
of our new captioning model you can see
this
image and the generated caption is
a statue of liberty in front of a city
here we color the novel objects in red
so here the statue of liberty is the
novel object recognized by the model
and for this image the caption is
a teddy bear wearing a bow tie
here both tidy bare and tie as knob
objects
and in this image the generated caption
is
two monkeys with their faces touching
a monkey is the knob object recognized
by the model
and in this uh for this image the
generated caption is
an elephant and it's cuffed in your
field and here the elephant's
a cuff filled up all the novel objects
okay now uh let's look at
a video demo of the new captioning model
here you will see
more examples of the caption results
from the new
captioning model
[Music]
so
here we provide more resources if you
want to learn more about the performance
of our new model and how to use our
model in your own projects
now here this is the link of the
demonstration website
if you want to test how the model works
on your own images
and you can upload your images in this
website and see the generated captions
and this is the documentation page for
the image captioning service
it is shipped in computer vision
cognitive services
you can call this endpoint to get the
description of the image
and it provides both rest api and the
sdk
so it's very easy to use the model in
your own project
we hope that everyone can enjoy the
latest technology of artificial
intelligence and in a convenient way
so no matter what errors you are working
on you can integrate the state of art
artificial intelligence model in your
own projects
by using our cognitive services
and our code and model are also
available on github
you can go to this repository if you
want to if you are interested in more
details
in implementation and you can also
fine-tune the model on your own data
here are some products in microsoft that
use our captioning service
this feature is called auto auth text
it is available in word powerpoint and
outlook
and when you insert an image in these
apps
it will automatically generate a
description
and this is one of the accessibility
features we provide in
office products
and our model is also used in cnaa
and it is a mobile app designed for
visually impaired people
it helps people to see through the
camera with the help of
various computer vision technologies
okay uh so this is the end of uh the
tutorial
and in the uh live q and a session uh my
manager region and i
will both join the q a session to answer
all your questions thank you
uh hi everyone thanks for attending
our webinar today on recent advances
i aimed captioning and now it's the live
q a
i'm legion wang and this is xiaoweihu
so over the next 15 minutes we're going
to be answering top questions submitted
by the audience
let's get started so the
first question is
um do you consider
image captioning as solve the problem um
like imagenet and or when do you think
it will be solved
i think it is a good question so uh
first thanks for the question and to be
honest we don't think that
image captioning is a soft problem yeah
so um what we observe
is that even with our best model we
still
see those kind of unsatisfying generator
captions
so because still um
it will depend on the data and the model
to learn to learn how to generate
captions and
you can also imagine um for the
images in the wild that there can be a
large variety of
objects and the visual concept so far
current
uh currently does not cover in our free
training
and so we think about of vivo
training is the first step um
but still we need to scale up the
pre-training
and make the captioning
really descriptive and uh
and achieve the human human parity so
so so right now we are on the no cavs so
we surpassed the
um sight of god compared with the human
skull
but that's only the the cytometric
so yeah
shall we please go ahead for the second
question
uh okay yeah uh
uh i will uh answer the question
about uh
oh okay i will answer the question about
uh
where you present some comparison
between
a birth and the gbt3
yeah because here uh in our
um in our tasks we study the vision
language pretrini
which uses like image captioning as the
downstream task
but since that birth and gp3 are purely
language models
and it only has the transformer part so
it's not that equivalent to our model
for the vision language tasks and here
in our model we only choose the
same transformer structure as birds
but we did not compare it with the gpd3
but we think
yeah it is a good direction to
try the different kind of transformer
structures in the visual language model
that's it okay uh another question is
that
um do you have a data set of all
generated captions so that we can try
the
inverse task reconstructing images from
novel captions i think thanks for the
question
um there are some this i think this is a
very
hard research area right now so trying
to synthesize
or rendering images from captions so
like the
um people are aware that the most recent
uh
d-a-l-l-e that's the work from open ai
so um trying to
get give a text caption trying to render
the images
so um if you want to generate
a data set with the generated captions
you can
number one try our oscar github so we
have released
our image captioning model and code you
can use that
to generate captions for your image data
set and
also you you may want to consider just
to simply call our
cognitive service cloud endpoint to
to generate a caption so that's even
even more simple
uh okay uh i see uh there's a question
uh uh from rory
and the question is uh can you explain
how the captioning system works with low
quality photos
are there any observable limitations
with black and white images or lower
pixel density
similarly has the image captioning
system explored with art
yeah i think this is a really great
question and
this is about the limitation of
current models that is it
only has a good performance when the
testing data
is somewhat has a similar distribution
with the training data
yeah and for our captioning model i
think
it's uh it also suffers from such kind
of
problem uh we call it as domain
adaptation and
for the low quality images and the black
and white
images i think it depends on if these
images are included in the training data
and in our training first
we depend on the object detection model
to abstract image features
so maybe the app object detection model
is not very good at
uh uh detecting features from the
like the low quality images or the art
images
yeah but uh i think we can solve this
problem by
by adding uh those kinds of images into
training data
yeah thank you for this question
another question
from toolkit is there a relation
between the complexity of the object
detection model
used and the performance of the model
the answer is yes so we do observe
the the model the object detection model
is very critical
because it provides the visual feature
to the transformer for this kind of
multi-modality alignment
so in our object detection model the
object detection model right now
is a faster thin
model so and the model need to
be fine-tuned on the vg dataset in order
to
be able to um propose
more category object categories and also
have some flavor of big this kind of
attribute
um features so um
yeah this is very very important and
and we recently have another paper uh in
archive
i i can share the link later it's uh
we call it the be in vl so
make the visual matters in vision
language so that that paper
uh focus on improving the
visual feature extraction we found that
this can improve the
vision language model performance
significantly
yeah thank you again for the questions
uh okay uh
uh okay i see uh oh i will pick uh this
uh question uh the question is uh
in the video uh captions uh in before
section mostly
uh consisted saying a close-up of
something
uh what data set modifications you had
to do
to achieve these results uh first
we did not do the data set modification
but i think yeah but you are right that
a close-up of something is uh
very uh is usually observed
in the generated captions as it depends
on the data sources because in the
in the trinity data we use they consist
a lot of
captions like a close-up of something so
the model
learns to generate the captions in a
similar way
to describe it
yeah this is uh the answer
okay and the question from
alan which tools and applications are
better to integrate
our computer vision program to create a
mobile application or that
desktop application this is a good
question so um
so as uh we are from the microsoft
cognitive service team so
um it is very simple and easy
you can integrate our cloud endpoint
into
your mobile and task applications so
the the computer vision cloud api
actually
provides the image captioning capability
and also
the image tagging object detection those
kind of a basic function in computer
vision
so in our in our ios app called the
thing ar
actually that that is the is the mobile
app that
we we try to integrate many this kind of
cloud api
into this kind of ios mobile app to let
that thing ai is trying to help the low
vision people
and to recognize and describe the things
around them
so i think that that's so the
um tip the short answer is that just
try out cloud api thank you
yeah i will take the next question the
question is
can oscar be used for fine-tuning our
novel tasks
like tasks it wasn't fine-tuned earlier
like bird is used for summarization yeah
the answer is
uh of course yes uh yeah and
in the paper of oscar we we have
a show we have shown our scientific
results on
seven downstream uh vision language
tasks
including the image captioning uh visual
question authoring
and multimodal image retrieval and
some other some other downstream fine
tuning tasks
and oscar has outperformed
the state of arts results at that time
on
on the seven downstream tasks so we
think
the pre-trained outcome model is a very
uh has vary uh has learned a very good
visual visual text alignment and
so it can be fine-tuned on the
downstream visual language tasks with a
very good performance
yeah and of course you can try it on
your own data or your own task
to see how how it performs thank you
okay so the other question is that
do you plan to extend or extrapolate
to videos from images so and understand
it as
another level of complexity um that's a
that's a
good question so so as you know that
uh today we are mainly talk about those
kind of image language pre-training
and also downstream is downstream task
is
image captioning or novel image
captioning novel object captioning
and um since
2019 so the video language pre-training
and also the downstream tasks are also
very hard area so people are using the
video and the video transcription to do
this kind of video language training
so we are looking into this area and
and the this kind of complexity you can
imagine so the
the data scale is huge so that makes the
training
that um much more heavy
heavier than the image lab imaging
language
pre-training but this can
because that the test once the tempo is
being added
you can imagine it can solve things like
that
video captioning describe a video uh
using
natural language and it can also do
those kind of a video recommendation
video text retrieval and even kind of
like the action recognition yeah so
it's a it's very interesting area so
yeah
thank you
okay i will take the next question
it's from raymond the question is
since you are training on millions of
image text combinations
how are you sure your test data is
different
maybe you are just retrieving captions
from the training set
yeah this is a very good question yeah
and the way
uh because we really want to uh avoid
this issue uh so in our uh
in our data pre-processing uh we have
very carefully cleaned the pre-training
and
fine-tuning data to ensure that there is
no overlap
between the pre-training and the
fine-tuning stage and the
testing stage and we have
because we have uh carefully identified
the image ids and the we also
uh use a visual feature extractor to
remove the images with very similar
features
as from the testing sets so i think
it is yeah it is a very important
thing to make sure that the training
data and the testing data do not
overlap and we have done this in our uh
all the ex of our experiments thank you
another question is um do you plan
integrate your work
in large web basis like social network
like facebook recently or image
search bing or google um
yeah i think um you imagine so it's a
it's a
cloud endpoint so you can integrate it
uh everywhere so in the
in the social social network app
or in the mobile app desktop app you can
do the integration
so currently we are integrating this
capability
in office so if you are using office
when you open your powerpoint your words
document
uh even your outlook if you insert an
image
into your powerpoint the
the powerpoint will call the image
captioning
cloud api and generating the ltx
uh auto our text for that image so
that helps improve the accessibility of
our whole office
uh product so uh yeah it
the very similar friendship
functionality you can find
in in the word document
and office when you write an email yeah
thank you
okay i will take this question
uh the question is uh is it possible to
uh throw more than one captions
for example assuming you get close
probabilities for possible capture
outputs
uh yes uh uh actually uh uh we
we also use uh uh we also use the bim
search uh method
in our caption generation and by setting
the
uh beam search set as like as a larger
number uh for example at five we can get
a lot of
uh candidate captures and uh you can
compare all the candidates and the
output of the one with the highest
probability
yeah this is my answer
um i saw a question
ask can this model also be used in
medical image diagnostic diagnosis
so i think that's a very interesting
question
so we haven't done any experiment for
medical image
but we believe that um
so this is trying to
align the language with the
visual feature so even for medical image
if we can have this kind of pair
it's not necessary to be a text sentence
to describe the medical it can be text
right
like what we did for vivo as long as you
have this kind of
text description along with the medical
image
yeah you can try such a model it will
help you
to do such kind of analysis
and maybe also can general generate
those kind of
magical image uh description thank you
i think the time is approaching
50 minutes yeah i believe it looks like
we
now we only have time for one more
question today
sorry can you pick the last question oh
okay
so uh i will take the
uh questions uh from uh tiango uh the
question is
uh where you test the model on domain
specific image data
with adapted pre-training uh for example
the satellite imaging
yeah uh i think this is a a good
question
now that is uh for a different kind of
images uh we may uh need
a different kind of pre-training yeah
but i think another direction
is to uh change uh is to train a
universal
uh large-scale uh preaching
model and the in the pre-training we can
we could contain as many types of images
as possible
that is it could include both the
natural images and the satellite images
and it's interes
it will be interesting to see that if
this kind of a universal progeny also
contributes
to the performance improvement thank you
okay um yeah so
thank you all for attending today
we appreciate your participation and
interest in this webinar
um if you are interested to learn more
uh we have list
some great resource in the result list
to the right of your screen
and we look forward to seeing how you
build
all this research and involved with the
vision language pre-training
and the image captioning space so
yeah have a great day bye-bye